محمد الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا
[Silence]
استووا واعتدلوادر
حاذوا بين المناكب وسدوا الفرج ولا
تختلفوا فتختلف قلوبكم
دبل
‏Make
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
سبحان الله
اعذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
وقال الملك ائتوني به استخلصه لنفسي
فلما كلمه قال انك اليوم لدينا مكين امين
قال اجعلني على خزائن
الارض اني حفيظ عليم
وكذلك مكنا ليوسف في الارض يتبوا منها حيث
يشاء
نصيب برحمتنا من نشاء
ولا نضيع اجر المحسنين
ولا اجر الاخره خير للذين امنوا وكانوا
يتقون
وجاء
اخوه يوسف فدخلوا عليه فعرفهم وهم له
منكرون
ولما جهزهم بجهازهم قال اتوني باخ لكم من
ابيكم
الا ترون اني اوفي الكيل وانا خير منزلين
فان لم تؤتوني به فلا كيل لكم عندي ولا
تقربون
فان لم تاتوني به فلا كيل لكم عندي ولا
قالوا سنراود عنه اباه وانا لفاعلون
وقال لفتيانه اجعلوا بضاعتهم في رحالهم
لعلهم يعرفونها
اذا انقلبوا الى اهلهم لعلهم يرجعون
فلما رجعوا الى ابيهم قالوا يا ابانا منع
منا الكيل
منع منا الكيل فارسل معنا اخانا نكتل وانا
له لحافظون
قال هل امنكم عليه الا كما امنتكم
على اخيه من قبل فالله خير حافظا
وهو ارحم الراحمين
ولما فتحوا متاعهم وجدوا بضاعتهم ردت
اليهم
قالوا يا ابانا ما نبغي
هذه بضاعتنا ردت الينا
ونمير اهلنا ونحفظ اخانا ونزداد كيل بعير
ذلك كيل
يسير
قال لن ارسله معكم حتى تؤتوني موثقا من
الله لتاتني
به لتاتنني
به الا ان يحاط بكم
فلما اتوه موثقهم قال الله على ما نقولك
نقول وكيل
قال الله على ما نقول وكيل
وقال يا بني لا تدخلوا من باب واحد
وادخلوا من ابواب
متفرقه
وما اغني عنكم
من الله من شيء
ان الحكم الا
عليه توكلت وعليه فليتوكل
المتوكلون
ولما دخلوا من حيث امرهم ابوهم ما كان
يغني عنهم من الله من شيء
الا حاجه في قلبي الا حاجه
الا حاجه في نفس يعقوب قضاها
وانه
لذو علم لما علمناه
ولكن اكثر الناس لا يعلمون
ولما دخلوا على يوسف اوى
اليه اخاه
قال اني انا اخوك فلا تبتئس بما كانوا
يعملون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
فلما جهزهم بجهازهم جعل السقايه في رحل
اخيه
ثم اذن مؤذن ايتها العير انكم لسارقون
قالوا واقبلوا عليهم ماذا تفقدون
قالوا نفقد صواع الملك ولمن جاء به حمل
بعير
حمل بعير وانا به زعيم
قالوا ت الله لقد علمتم ما جئنا لنفسد في
الارض وما كنا سارقين
قالوا فما جزاؤه
ان كنتم كاذبين
قالوا جزاؤه
من وجد في رحله فهو جزاؤه
كذلك نجزي الظالمين
فبدا باوعيه
هم قبل وعاء
اخيه
فبدا باوعيتهم قبل وعاء
ثم استخرجها من وعاء
اخيه
كذلك كدنا ليوسف
ما كان لياخذ اخاه في دين الملك الا ان
يشاء الله
نرفع درجات
من نشاء
وفوق كل ذي علم عليم
قالوا ان يسرق فقد سرق اخ له من قبل
فاسرها يوسف في نفسه ولم يبدها لهم قال
انتم شر مكانا والله اعلم بما تصفون
قالوا يا ايها العزيز ان له ابا شيقا
كبيرا
فخذ احدنا مكانه انا نراك من المحسنين
قال معاذ الله ان ناخذ الا من وجدنا
متاعنا عنده
انا
اذا لظالمون
فلما استياسوا منه خلصوا نجيا
قال كبيرهم الم تعلموا ان اباكم قد اخذ
عليكم موثقا من الله
ومن قبل ما فرضتم في يوسف
فلن ابرح الارض حتى ياذن لي ابي او يحكم
الله لي وهو خير الحاكمين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن من حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك المستقينا
الصراط المستقيم
بما انعمت عليهم خير
عليهم الضين
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليه
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
تحيه
اشهد ان الله اشهد
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر
আসসালামু আলাইকুম
question সিস্টার ইউ সপনস্টারড
অর
আর
বজড
ইনশাআল্লাহ
‏other
pleas
par
carele
parল্লাহি রাam
just par
‏to f because some are
dirt that kind of kicks in the air and
that creates a poution so pleas out
very gent and be humble you the
yesulfed
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما
المسيح الدجال المسيح الكذاب
notival
is
type
‏li
present the people
with
something rotten
but he gives it a nice image. It's all
about usion.
‏He is an individual who is
absolutely
enveloped in usion this is strongest
tool that he will use in to misguide
humanityusion
the question I have today
is has there ever in theory in theory
‏moreed
inusion
our time
lookusion
you up orang you up a watermelon at the
at the grocery stor
man it look so good look so juicy
‏And then you take it home and you bite
into it and it has no taste.
It doesn't really have a smell.
‏It's been engineered
to make it into your shing and out the
door and after that as
it look very good. ‏We look at our world
today. It looks really nice. Really
nice.
But seldom have things been more
terrible
in the history of human knowledge, human
ingenuity.
We very very good with the advent of the
internet the televion. ‏We are very good
at usions.
‏We're speaking about entire accounts,
Instagram accounts, Facebook accounts,
Tikts
with millions of followers
and
content
of
محتوى
ايش هذا؟ هذا صانع محتوى
صانع محتوى
الخطاب
محتوى
people
generated
‏usion
mag
exly
kinderday
propجal
will
mention among thel
[Silence]
‏How many you about
some may never in life
thrives in this kind ofol ofusion
‏and
and
we have to take these things andly them
to our yesterday we very reasonable
question
من نبي من قبلي الا وانذر قومه او امته
الدجال انذره نوح والنبيون من بعدها
[Silence]
نوح
صحيح مسلم صلى الله عليه وسلم
اذا فرغ احدكم من التشهد الاخر
فل
يستعد بالله من اربع
تشهد الصلاه الابراهيميه
[Silence]
جهنم اوكي
فتنه المحيا والممات
اللهمين
محمد صلى الله عليه
‏Have the maor if we gather all these
time most of them encounter
most of them
will half of them
what about
[Silence]
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
المسيح الدجال
[Silence]
‏We have that human being
spear head
but then we have the environment
we
‏aion
a mis
and
of us will enounter and will continue to
get worse and worse and worse and worse
until finally it will culminate in the
emergence of a man a real physical man
‏that will come out to humanity and
everything wrong with humanity
and he will thatit of aal
and our prop
tells us that will have a river of fire
and will have a river oftine cool
and
the question is what our
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
CNN breaking this maned you think won
happen or is CNN to official and they
never lie they don't tell any lies
they're very
‏you
because
these people much much more truth.
However, we still on them and we still
believe them. In general, we believe
that they are liar inherently but then
we believe their individual news
stories. ‏And not only that, but we
fight with each other over a story in
the
what is where coming where going we
don't
that
the media tells the truth all the time
question is what would we have done if
we were in the time of the propet
and the media at that time and the
talking heads at that time and the
leaders
ابو
جهل up equivalent
on
those
heroes and they come out
is he came up with this only this is he
insane he a poet
‏would you
mind and to not to age with anyck
this out
would you on the band wagon a way to
what you would is to look at your
are you
bandwon
[Silence]
ان شاء الله
باذن الله نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمني
وكرمي وجوده ان يبارك لي ولكم في القران
العظيم اساله تعالى ان يعيذني وايا اياكم
من عذاب جهنم ومن عذاب النار والقبر ومن
فتنه المحيا والممات ومن شر فتنه المسيح
الدجال والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد
[Silence]
بسم الله
بسم لا
[Silence]
اله الا
استووا واعتدلوا
حاذوا بين المناكب وسدوا الفرج
[Silence]
الله
اكبر اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
فلما استياسوا منه خلصوا نجيا
قال كبيرهم الم تعلموا ان اباكم قد اخذ
عليكم موثقا من الله
ومن قبل ما فرضتم في يوسف
فلن ابرح الارض حتى ياذن لي ابي او يحكم
الله لي وهو خير الحاكمين
ارجعوا الى ابيكم فقولوا يا ابانا ان ابنك
سرق
وما شهدنا الا بما علمنا وما كنا للغيب
حافظ حافظين
واسال القريه التي كنا فيها والعير التي
اقبلنا فيها
وانا لصادقون
قال بل سولت لكم انفسكم امرا فصبر
جميل
فصبر
عسى الله ان ياتيني بهم جميعا
انه هو العليم الحكيم
وتولى عنهم وقال يا اسفا على يوسف
وابيضت عيناه من الحزن فهو كظيم
قالوا ت الله تفت
تذكر يوسف حتى تكون حرضا او تكون من
الهالكين
قال انما
اشكو بثي وحزني
الى الله
واعلم من الله ما لا تعلمون
يا بني اذهبوا فتحسسوا من يوسف يوسف واخيه
ولا تياسوا من روح الله
انه لا يياس من روح الله الا القوم
الكافرون
فلما دخلوا عليه قالوا يا ايها العزيز
مسنا واهلنا الضر
وجئنا ببضاعه
مزجاه فاوف لنا الكيل وتصدق علينا
ان الله يجزي المتصدقين
قال هل علمتم
ما فعلتم بيوسف واخيه اذ انتم جاهلون
قالوا اانك
لانت يوسف
قال انا يوسف وهذا اخي قد من الله علينا
انه من يتقبر
فان الله لا يضيع اجر المحسنين
قالوا ت الله لقد اثرك الله علينا وان كنا
لخاطئين
قال لا تثريب عليكم اليوم
يغفر الله لكم وهو ارحم الراحمين
اذهبوا بقميصي هذا فالقوه على وجه ابي يات
بصيرا
واتوني باهلكم اجمعين
ولما فصلت العير قال ابوهم اني لاجد ريح
يوسف لولا ان تفندون
قالوا الله انك لفي ضلالك القديم
فلما
ان جاء
البشير القاه على وجهه فارتد بصيرا
قال الم اقل لكم اني اعلم من الله ما لا
تعلمون
قالوا يا ابانا استغفر لنا ذنوبنا
استغفر لنا ذنوبنا انا
كنا خاطئين
قال سوف استغفر لكم ربي
انه
هو الغفور الرحيم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
فلما دخلوا على يوسف اوى
اليه ابويه
وقال ادخلوا مصر ان شاء
الله امنين
ورفع ابويه على العرش وخروا له سجدا
قال يا ابتويل
رؤياي من قبل جعلها ربي حقا
وقد احسن بي اذ اخرجني من السجن وجاء بكم
من البدو من بعد ان نزغ
من بعد ان نزغ الشيطان بيني وبين اخوتي
ان ربي لطيف لما يشاء
انه
هو العليم الحكيم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
كنك مشيت كم شغاله
بساله
الاولى
يا قال يا
قال يا انا قلت ايش قال لا
[Arabic recitation]
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
رب قد اتيتني من الملك وعلمتني من تاويل
الاحاديث
فاطر السماوات والارض انت وليي في الدنيا
والاخره
توفني مسلما
والحقني بالص الصالحين
ذلك من انباء
الغيب نوحيه اليك وما كنت لديهم اذ اجمعوا
امرهم وهم يمكرون
وما اكثر
الناس ولو حرست بمؤمنين
وما تسالهم عليه من اجر ان هو الا ذكر
العالمين
وكاي من ايه في السماوات والارض يمرون
عليها وهم عنها معرضون
وما يؤمن اكثرهم
بالله الا وهم مشركون
افان ان تاتيهم غاشيه من عذاب الله او
تاتيه م الساعه بغته وهم لا
يشعرون
قل هذه سبيلي ادعو الى الله على بصيره انا
ومن اتبعني
وسبحان الله وما انا من المشركين
وما ارسلنا قبلك وما ارسلنا من قبلك الا
رجالا نوح حي اليهم من اهل القرى افلم
يسيروا في الارض فينظروا كيف كان عاقبه
الذين من قبلهم
ولدار الاخره خير للذين اتقوا افلا تعقلون
حتى اذا استياس الرسل وظنوا انهم قد كذبوا
جاءهم
نصرنا فنجي من
نشاء
ولا يرد باسنا عن القوم المجرمين
لقد كان في قصصهم عبره لاولي الالباب
ما كان حديثا يفترى
ولكن تصديق الذي بين يديه
وتفصيل كل شيء
وهدى ورحمه لقوم
يؤمنون
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
المرا
تلك ايات الكتاب والذي الذي انزل اليك من
ربك الحق ولكن اكثر الناس لا يؤمنون
الله الذي رفع السماوات بغير عمد ترونها
ثم استوى على العرش وسخر الشمس والقمر كل
يجري لاجل مسمى
يدبر الامر يفصل صل الايات
يدبر الامر يفصل الايات لعلكم بلقاء ربكم
توقنون
وهو الذي مد الارض وجعل فيها رواسي
وانهارا
ومن كل الثمرات جعل فيها زوجين اثنين يغشي
الليل النهار
ان في ذلك لايات لقوم يتذكرون
وفي الارض قطع متجاورات
وجنات
من اعناب
وزرع ونخيل
وزرع ونخيل سنوان وغير سنوان
وغير وغير
سن صن سن صنوان وغير وغير وغير سنوان يسقى
بماء
واحد ونفضل بعضها على بعض في الاكل
ان في ذلك لايات
لقوم
يعقلون
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك اياك
نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
وان تعجب فعجبوا قولهم
ائذا كنا ترابا
اانا لفي خلق جديد
اولئك الذين كفروا بربهم
واولئك
الاغلال في اعناقهم
اصحاب النار هم فيها خالدون
ويستعجلونك
بالسيئه قبل حسنه وقد خلت من قبلهم الملات
وان ربك لذو مغفره للناس على ظلمهم
وان ربك لشديد العقاب ويقول الذين كفروا
لولا انزل عليه ايه من ربه انما انت منذر
ولكل قوم
الله يعلم ما تحمل كل انثى وما تغيض
الارحام وما تغيض الارحام وما تزداد
وكل شيء عنده بمقدار
عالم الغيب والشهاده الكبير المتعال
سواء
منكم من اسر والقول ومن جهر به ومن هو
مستخف
بالليل وسارب بالنهار
له معقبات
من بين يديه ومن خلفه يحفظونه من امر الله
ان الله لا يغير ما بقوم حتى يويونا
بانفسهم
اذا اراد الله بقوم
سوءا
فلا مرد له
فلا مرد له وما لهم من الله من وال
وما لهم من دونه من والذي
يريكم البرق خوفا وطمعا
وينشئ
السحاب
الثقال
ويسبح الرعد بحمده والملائكه
من خيفته ويرسل الصواعق فيصيب بها من يشاء
وهم يجادلون في الله وهو شديد المحال له
دعوه الحق
وله دعوه الحق والذين يدعون
من دونه لا يستجيبون
لا يستجيبون لهم بشيء الا كباسط كفيه الى
الماء ليبلغ فاه
ليبلغاه
وما هو ببالغه
وما دعاء
الكافرين الا في ضلال ولله يسجد من في
السماء السماوات والارض طوعا وكرها
وظلالهم
بالغدو
والاصان
[Arabic recitation]
قل من رب السماوات والارض قل الله قل
افاتخذتم
من دونه
اولياء
لا يملكون لانفسهم نفعا ولا ضرا
قل هل يستوي الاعمى والبصير ام هل تستوي
الظلمات والنور
وجعلوا لله شركاء
خلقوا كخلقه فتشابه الخلق عليهم
ام جعلوا لله شركاء
خلقوا كخلقه فتشابه الخلق عليهم قل الله
خالق كل شيء وهو الواحد القهار
انزل من السماء
ماء
فسالت اوديه
بقدرها
فاحتمل السيل زبد رايا ومما يوقدون عليه
في النار ابتغاء
حيه او متاع زبد مثله كذلك يضرب الله الحق
والباطل
فاما
الزبد فيذهب جفاء
واما ما ينفع
الناس فيمكث في الارض كذلك يضرب الله
الامثال للذين استجابوا لربهم الحسنى
والذين لم يستجيبوا له لو ان لهم ما في
الارض جميعا
لو ان لهم ما في الارض جميعا ومثله معه
لافتدوا به
اولئك
لهم سوء
الحساب
وماواهم جهنم
وبئس الجهاد
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استا
[Silence]
‏I move it. Yeah, I know. ‏why
why you guys I
[Silence]
شيخ
بس لا
[Silence]
الله
طيب
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدل استو
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم رحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
افمن يعلم
انما انزل اليك من ربك الحق كمن هو اعمى
انما يتذكر اولو الالباب
الذين يوفون بعهد الله ولا ينقضون الميثاق
والذين يصلون ما امر الله به ان يوصل
ويخشون ربهم ويخشون ربهم ويخافون
سوء
الحساب
والذين صبروا ابتغاء
وجه ربهم واقاموا الصلاه وانفقوه
وانفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا وعلانيه
ويدرؤون بالحسنه السيئه اولئك
لهم عقد الدار جنات
عدن
يدخلونها
ومن صلح من ابائهم
وازواجهم
وذرياتهم
والملائكه
يدخلون عليهم من كل باب
سلام عليكم بما صبرتم فنعم عقد الدار
والذين الين ينقضون عهد الله من بعد
ميثاقه ويقطعون
ويقطعون ما امر الله به ان يوصل ويفسدون
ويفسدون في الارض اولئك
لهم اللعنه ولهم سوء الدار
الله يبسط الرزق لمن يشاء
ويقدر
وفرحوا بالحياه الدنيا وما الحياه الدنيا
في الاخره الا متاع ويقول الذين كفروا
ويقول الذين كفروا لولا انزل عليه ايه من
ربه قل ان الله يضل قل ان الله يضل من
يشاء
ويهدي اليه من اناب
الذين امنوا وتطمئن
قلوبهم بذكر الله
الا بذكر الله تطمئن
القلوب
الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات توبى
طوب لهم وحسن
كذلك ارسلناك في امه قد خلت من قبلها امم
لتتلوه لتتلو عليهم الذي اوحينا اليك وهم
يكفرون بالرحمن
قل هو ربي لا اله الا هو قل هو ربي لا اله
الا هو عليه توكلت واليه متاب
ولو ان قرانا سيرت به الجبال او قطعت به
الارض
او قطعت به الارض او كلم به موتا بل لله
الامر جميعا
افلم يياس الذين امنوا لو يشاء الله لهدى
الناس جميعا
ولا يزال الذين كفروا تصيبهم بما صنعوا
قارعه تصيبهم بما صنعوا قارعه او تحل
قريبا من دارهم حتى
ياتي وعد الله
ان الله لا يخلف الميعاد
ولقد استهزئ برسل من قبلك فامليت ل
للذين كفروا فامليت للذين كفروا ثم اخذتهم
فكيف كان عقاب
افمن هو قائم على كل نفس بما كسبت وجعلوا
لله شركاء
قل سموهم
ام تنبئونه بما لا يعلم في الارض ام بظاهر
من القول
بل زين للذين كفروا مكرهم وصدوا عن السبيل
ومن يضلل الله فما له من هاد
لهم عذاب
في الحياه الدنيا
ولا عذاب الاخره اشق
ولعذاب الاخره اشق وما لهم من الله من واق
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
مثل الجنه التي وعد المتقون تجري من تحتها
الانهار
تجري من تحتها الانهار اكلها دائم
وظلها
تلك عقب الذين اتقوا وعقب الكافرين
النار
والذين اتيناهم الكتاب يفرحون بما انزل
اليك ومن الاحزاب من ينكر بعضه قل انما
امرت ان اعبد الله ولا اشرك به اليه ادعو
واليه ماب وكذلك انزلناه
حكم ركنا عربيا
ولئن اتبعت اهواءهم
بعد ما جاءك
من العلم ما لك من الله من ولي ولا واق
ولقد ارسلنا رسلا من قبلك وجعلنا لهم
ازواجا وذريه
وما كان لرسول ان ياتي بايه الا باذن الله
لكل اجل كتاب
يمحو الله ما يشاء
ويثبت وعنده
ام الكتاب
واما نرينك بعض الذي نعدهم او نتوثينك
فانما
عليك البلاغ وعلينا الحساب
اولم يروا انا ناتي الارض ننقصها من
اطرافها
والله يحكم لا يعقب لحكمه وهو سريع الحساب
ولقد مكر الذين من قبلهم فلله
وقد مكر الذين من قبلهم فلله
المكر جميعا
يعلم ما تكسب كل نفس وسيعلم الكفار لمن
عقب الدار ويقول الذين كفروا لست مرسلا
قل كفى بالله شهيدا بيني وبينكم
ومن عنده
علم كتاب
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الم
ر كتاب انزلناه اليك لتخرج
الناس من الظلمات الى النور باذن ربهم
باذن ربهم الى صراط العزيز الحميد
الله الذي له ملك الله الذي له ما في
السماوات وما في الارض
وويل للكافرين
من عذاب شديد
الذين يستحبون الحياه الدنيا على الاخره
ويصدون عن سبيل الله ويصدون عن سبيل الله
ويبغونها
عوجا
اولئك
في ضلال بعيد
وما ارسلنا من رسول الا بلسان قومه ليبين
لهم فيضل الله من يشاء
ويهدي من يشاء
وهو العزيز الحكيم ولقد ارسلنا موسى بايات
ان اخرج قومك ان اخرج قومك من الظلمات الى
النور وذكرهم بايام الله
ان في ذلك لايات لكل صبار شكور واذ قال
موسى لقومه اذكروا نعمه الله عليكم اذ
انجاكم
من ال فرعون يسومونكم سوء العذاب
ويذبحون ابناءكم
ويستحيون
نساءكم
وفي ذلكم بلاء
من ربكم عظيم
واذ تاذن ربكم لئن شكرتم لازيدنكم
ولئن كفرتم ان عذا عذابي لشديد
وقال موسى ان تكفروا انتم ومن في الارض
جميعا
فان
الله لغني حميد
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
الم ياتكم نبا الذين من قبلكم قوم نوح
وعاد وثمود والذين من بعدهم لا يعلمهم الا
الله
جاءتهم
رسلهم بالبينات فردوا ايديهم في افواههم
وقالوا
وقالوا انا كفرنا بما ارسلتم به وانا لفي
شك مما تدعوننا اليه مريب
قالت رسلهم افي الله شك فاطر السماوات
والارض يدعوكم ليغفر لكم
يدعوكم ليغفر لكم من ذنوبكم ويؤخركم
الى اجل مسمى
قالوا ان انتم الا بشر مثلنا تريدون ان
تريدون ان تصدونا عما كان يعبد اباؤنا
فاتونا بسلطان مبين
قالت لهم رسلهم ان نحن الا بشر مثلكم ولكن
الله يمن على من يشاء من عباده
وما كان لنا ان ناتيكم بسلطان الا باذن
الله
وعلى الله فليتوكل المؤمنون
وما لنا الا نتوكل على الله وقد هدانا
سبلنا
ولنصبرن
على ما اذيتمونا
وعلى الله فليتوكل المتوكلون.
وقال الذين كفروا لرسلهم لنخرجنكم
من ارضنا او لتعودن في ملتنا
فاوحى اليهم ربهم لنهلكن الظالمين
ولنسكننكم
الارض من بعدهم ذلك لمن خاف مقامي وخاف
وعيد
واستفتحوا وخاب جبار ار عنيد
من ورائه
جهنم ويسقى من ماء
صديد
يتجرعه ولا يكاد يسيغه وياتيه الموت من كل
مكان وما هو بميت
ومن ورائه
عذاب غليظ
مثل الذين كفروا بربهم اعمالهم كرماد
اشتدت به الريح في يوم عاصف لا يقدرون مما
كسبوا على شيء اولئك
اولئك في الضلال البعيد
ذلك هو الضلال البعيد
الم تر ان الله خلق السماوات
والارض بالحق ان يشا يذهبكم ويات بخلق
جديد وما ذلك على الله بعزيز
وبرزوا لله جميعا فقال الضعفاء
للذين استكبروا انا كنا لكم تبعا
فقال الضعفاء
فهل انتم مغنون عنا من عذاب الله من شيء
قالوا لو هدانا الله لهديناكم
سواء
علينا اجزعنا ام صبرنا ما لنا من محيص
وقال الشيطان لما قضي الامر ان الله وعدكم
وعد الحق ووعدتكم فاخلفتكم
وما كان عليكم من سلطان الا ان دعوتكم
فاستجبتم لي
فلا تلوموني ولوموا انفسكم
ما انا بمصرخكم وما انتم بمصرخي
اني كفرت بما اشركتموني من قبل ان
الظالمين لهم عذاب اليم
وادخل الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها باذن
ربهم
تحيتهم فيها سلام
الم تر كيف ضرب الله مثلا كلمه طيبه كشجره
طيبه
اصلها ثابت وفرعها في السماء
تؤتي اكلها كل حين باذن ربها ويضرب الله
الامثال للناس لعلهم يتذكرون
ومثل كلمه خبيثه كشجره خبيثه اجتثت من فوق
الارض ما لها من قرار
يثبت الله الذين امنوا بالقول الثابت في
الحياه الدنيا وفي الاخره
ويضل الله الظالمين
ويفعل الله ما يشاء
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
الم تر الى الذين بدلوا نعمه الله كفرا
واحلوا قومهم دار البوار
جهنم يصلونها وبئس القرار
وجعلوا لله اندادا ليضلوا عن سبيله قل
تمتعوا فان مصيركم الى النار
قل لعبادي الذين امنوا يقيموا الصلاه
وينفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا وعلانيه
وينفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا وعلانيه من قبل
ان ياتي يوم لا بيع فيه ولا خلال
الله الذي خلق السماوات والارض وانزل
من السماء
ماء فاخرج به من الثمرات رزقا لكم
وسخر لكم الفلك لتجري في البحر بامره وسخر
لكم الانهار
وسخر لكم الشمس والقمر دائبين
وسخر لكم الليل والنهار
واتاكم من كل ما سالتموه
وان تعدوا نعمه الله لا تحصوها
ان الانسان لظلوم كفار
واذ قال ابراهيم رب اجعل هذا البلد امنا
واجنبني وبني ان نعبد الاصنام
رب انهن اضللن كثيرا من الناس فمن تبعني
فانه مني ومن عصاني فانك غفور رحيم
ربنا اني اسكنت من ذريتي بواد غيرذ ذي زرع
عند بيتك المحرم ربنا ليقيموا الصلاه
فاجعل افئده من الناس تهوي اليهم وارزقهم
من الثمرات لعلهم يشكرون
ربنا انك تعلم ما نخفي وما نعلن وما يخفى
على الله من شيء في الارض ولا في السماء
ماء
الحمد لله الذي وهبني على الكبر اسماعيل
واسحاق
ان ربي لسميع الدعاء
رب اجعلني مقيم الصلاه ومن ذريتي
ربنا وتقبل دعاء
ربنا اغفر لي ولوالدي وللمؤمنين يوم يقوم
الحساب
ولا تحسبن
الله غافلا عما يعمل الظالمون
انما يؤخرهم ليوم تشخص فيه الابصار
مهطعين مقنعي رؤوسهم لا يرتد اليهم طرفهم
وافئدتهم هواء
انذر الناس يوم ياتيهم العذاب فيقول الذين
ظلموا ربنا اخرنا الى اجل قريب نجب دعوتك
ونتبع الرسل اولم تكونوا اقسمتم من قبل ما
لكم من زوال
وسكنتم في مساكن الذين ظلموا انفسهم وتبين
لكم كيف فعلنا بهم
وضربنا لكم الامثال
وقد مكروا مكرهم وعند الله مكرهم وان كان
مكرهم لتزول منه الجبال
فلا تحسبن الله مخلف وعده رسله
ان الله عزيز ذو انتقام
يوم تبدل الارض غير الارض والسماوات
وبرزوا لله الواحد القهار
وترى المجرمين يومئذ مقرنين في الاصفاد
سرابيلهم
من قطران
وتغشى وجوههم النار
ليجزي الله كل نفس ما كسبت ان الله سريع
الحساب
هذا بلاغ للناس ولينذروا
به وليعلموا انما هو اله واحد وليذكر اولو
الالباب
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
ورحمه الله.
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
احسنت
[Silence]
استووادلوا
الصف
بس
[Arabic recitation]
وتبارك اسمك وتعالى جدك الهرك اعذ من
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
من شر ما خلق ومن شر غاسق اذا وقب
ومن شر النفاثات
في العقد
ومن شر حاسد اذا حسد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
قل اعوذ برب
الناس
ملك
اله
الناس
من شر الوسواس الخناس الذي يوسوس في صدور
من الجنه
والناس
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت
وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه
لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت
ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
ربنا لك الحمد حتى ترضى
ولك الحمد اذا رضيت
ولك الحمد بعد الرضا ولك الحمد على كل حال
لك الحمد انت نور السماوات والارض لك
الحمد وانت قيوم السماوات والارض يا رحمن
يا رحيم
يا رحمن الدنيا والاخره
ورحيمهما
اللهم
اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا وبين
معصيتك
ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك
ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب
الدنيا
ومتع عنا اللهم
بابصارنا
واسماعنا
وقواتنا
ما احييتنا
واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثارنا على من
ظلمنا
وانصرنا
على من عادانا
اللهم
اننا نعوذ بك من جهد البلاء
ودرك الشقاء
وسوء
القضاء
وشماته الاعداء
اللهم
اننا نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء
ومرافقه
الانبياء
والنصر على الاعداء
يا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء
اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
واخذل الشرك والمشركين
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم
انصر اخواننا المجاهدين
المطاهدين
في غزه وفلسطين
وفي السودان وفي كل مكان
حيث حلوا يا رحمن
اللهم انصرهم على من عاداهم
اللهم انصرهم
على من عاداهم
واجعل ثارهم على من ظلمهم اللهم انصرهم
على عدوهم
واجعلهم على عدوهم ظاهرين
واجعلهم على عدوهم قاهرين
عالين
منصورين
عزيزين
اللهم عليك بعدوك وعدوهم
فانهم
لا يعجزونك
اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون اللعين
اللهم زلزل اركانا
وصدع بنيانا
واقتل اجنادا
اللهم قذف الرعب في قلوبهم
اللهم اقدف الرعب في قلوبهم
واضرب عليهم الذله والهوان
واقطع حبالهم بينهم وبين الناس
اللهم اجعل احياءهم
في ذل وهوان
واجعل قتلهم في النيران
واجعل قتلاهم
في النيران
واجعل شهداءنا
في الجنان
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر
سبحان
الله
[Arabic recitation]
رسول الله صل على محمد
اللهم بارك على محمد
[Arabic recitation]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان الملك القدوس
سبحان
الملك القدوس
[Silence]
الله يعفيك
الحمد
[Silence]
يا
السلام